they are out there lurking just out of
sight until and make their presence
known rattlesnakes have a dangerous
reputation but the threat is exaggerated
Rattlers just want you to leave them
alone give them a wide berth and they'll
do the same but if a rattlesnake is
surprised it may strike in self-defense
and its bite can be lethal the vast
majority of snakebite victims survive
their encounter only a handful die each
year the deciding factor is time if
you're bitten by a rattlesnake what
should you do 8 pack the wound with ice
be keep the wound immobilized below the
heart or sea suck out the poison with
your mouth the correct answer is B
keep the wound immobilized below the
heart packing the wound with ice and
sucking out the poison with your mouth
do little to slow down the venom they
can actually cause more harm than good
rattlesnake venom causes extreme pain
swelling so it's important to stay calm
and stay focused keep the wounded area
still and below the heart to help slow
the spread of the venom then immediately
call 9-1-1 or go to the hospital
and that's how you survive a rattlesnake
bite